cabaret bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france david xavier
weiss devait être avec nous ils
devraient peut-être arriver on va
commencer sans lui peut-être avant de
parler du nucléaire emmanuel macron
arrive avec jean pierre chevènement à
belfort cet après midi dans ses bagages
pour une caution souverainistes à gauche
un déplacement hautement politique
d'autant qu'on a appris qu'eric woerth
rejoignait la république en marche c'est
une bonne pioche pour vous
eric woerth toute personne qui rejoint
d'un république en marché qui était qui
est une est une bonne pioche c'est vous
qui êtes avis et 7 ce constat c'est un
c'est réaliste de la part de monsieur
woerth que de venir auprès d'emmanuel
maquiller pour tous - eh bien peut-être
poursuivre sa vie politique
jean pierre chevènement également dans
les bagages on lisait du président pour
quel message selon vous
je crois que d'abord je vais revenir sur
juste que j'ai entendu précédemment et
sur
l'industrie et notre président je crois
que il ne fait aucun doute aujourd'hui
que l'industrie a été préservé par notre
président de la république pendant des
mois et je dirais des années nous avons
ces deux dernières années nous avons eu
des culs des zones de grands risques et
chaque industriel reconnaît l'efficacité
et la réactivité et un gouvernement qui
réagissent vite est un régime est un
gouvernement qui qui a su adapter
l'ensemble de ces
de ses projets à une aînée à une
industrie qui étaient en souffrance
pendant la crise commis
donc on à préserver l'industrie
préserver l'emploi et j'entendais 2014
mais vous savez qu entre 2014 et 2020 2
qui s'écoule bien des années bien des
vues et bien justement cette réactivité
cette agilité qui président de la
république à être concerné par ce qui se
passe et être réactif sur sur les choix
eh bien ça nous préserve bien des dégâts
mais selon vous sept ans après avoir été
vendu par alstom à l'entreprise
américaine general electric cette vente
signée par emmanuel macron alarmistes de
l'économie est ce que à l'époque c'était
une mauvaise décision avec le recul
moi je me permettrai pas d'abord je
connais pas ce sujet particulièrement
bien et je me permettrais pas de dire si
c'était une bonne ou une mauvaise
nouvelle mauvaise chose donc ça m'est
difficile de vous répondre à une
question aussi
qui remonte en arrière
quand on revoit l'histoire vous savez où
on la refait différemment parfois mais
c'est pas pour autant qu'on s'en serait
mieux sorti en tout cas le président de
la république qui va donc s'exprimer sur
sa stratégie énergétique
on sait qu'il veut notamment miser sur
la relance du nucléaire pour une france
décarbonés et en même temps regardez ce
qu'a déclaré hier barbara conflit la
ministre de la transition écologique
on a remonté un petit peu le quota de
charbon parce qu'on a besoin de marge de
manoeuvre à cause de réacteurs
nucléaires qui sont arrêtés alors qu'ils
n'auraient pas dû l'être mais on est sur
des proportions qui sont très très petit
c'est 2 à 3 % de notre production
d'électricité etc 0,2 pour cent de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
france est-ce que c'est pas un compte
tout de même d'augmenter sa production
charbon aujourd'hui après avoir fermé
notamment fessenheim ces barrières ne
fermer une centrale est ce que ça a été
une erreur lareau là aussi elles
fessenheim ça a été du courage ça a été
une erreur les sonnailles on a parlé
combien de temps avant d'arriver à avoir
le courage de faire ce qui avait été dit
et c'est qu'ils avaient été peints
suggéré par énormément de textes
d'experts donc fessenheim on va pas
revenir dessus sans arrêt à se demander
si on a fait une erreur ou pas à la
ferme et en question de sûreté chacun
sait que fessenheim était sur une fine
en plus et est arrivé en bout de course
donc on va pas préservons va pas
continuer à conserver des centrales que
diraient les personnes que dit la
population si on lui dit conservons des
centrales des ppte
nucléaire au risque d'un accident parce
que finalement c'est un peu ça mais non
c'est pas c'est pas du tout c'est pas du
tout la fonction d'un président de la
république qui est de protéger les
français que de que de conserver des
idées des industries et des centrales
nucléaires qui ne peuvent pas être
qui ne peuvent ou ne peuvent pas
répondre à la sûreté pierre cabaye on va
poursuivre tous les deux parce que david
xavier weiss malheureusement va pas
pouvoir nous rejoindre ce matin on va
continuer à parler du nucléaire
justement de vous disais donc fermer
fessenheim et et en même temps tout de
même misé sur cette énergie nucléaire il
n'y a pas d'autre choix aujourd'hui
je crois que
on peut pas on peut pas avoir d'autre
choix que d'aller vers le nucléaire
quand on veut absolument
décarbonés décarbonés l'énergie 2050
c'est pendant trop longtemps
aujourd'hui on a un mix énergétique
demain il faudra décarbonés en totalité
donc l'énergie nucléaire me paraît un
élément absolument indispensable et puis
on va pas revenir sur une technologie
que la france maîtrise particulièrement
bien je crois que chaque syndicat est
très heureux de voir que finalement on
crée des emplois ont créé une
mine force une
dire une
une valeur une richesse
et tout et tout ça dans la sûreté donc
on va pas remettre en cause mais moi je
voudrais juste revenir une chose c'est
que normalement il y avait un débat ce
matin bon j'entends bien que monsieur
bay ce n'est pas là mais je voudrais
dire que
j'entends l'idée l'image d'un plan de
relance gaullien de madame pécresse on
nous on a un président de la république
à la manoeuvre et il a pas il a un plan
un vrai plan
c'est pas un projet est d'ailleurs quand
valérie pécresse fait un projet qu'elle
ouvre un tiroir certes parfois un peu
poussiéreux et bien on s'aperçoit et
emmanuel macron ce projet a déjà été
réalisées donc
je trouve d'abord je regrette qu'il soit
paré pour pouvoir répondre mais je
trouve aussi que il faut pas faire de il
faut aller vers l'avenir et il ne faut
pas faire de
deux mauvais de mauvais procès à tout ce
qui a déjà été fait donc aujourd'hui il
faut miser sur le nucléaire c'est ce que
vous nous dites sans pour autant ouvrir
d'autres réacteurs ont créé davantage de
centrales moi je pense qu'il faut que je
peux pas vous dire ce que ce qui va être
être proposée par la saison de la
république cet après midi mais bien
entendu que il faut certainement ouvrir
d'autres centrales des
réacteurs mais surtout il faut remplacer
et rafraîchir notre partenaire
parmi les énergies renouvelables il y en
a une qui fait débat régulièrement c'est
l'éolien
c'était une nécessité vitale 1 avait
d'ailleurs dit en octobre 2021 barbara
pompili mais beaucoup refusant voir ces
l'éolienne gâcher leurs paysages
notamment dans les zones rurales ou en
bord de mer à l'éolien au fond c'est une
mauvaise idée ou pas aujourd'hui
d'un écouter sais pas s'il ya des
personnes qui pensent que l'éolien peut
répondre à notre une une part de notre
indépendance énergétique à une part de
notre production d'énergie renouvelable
je pense que
trop c'est certainement c'est
certainement trop de l'éolien serait
serait nuisible au paysage
on entre dans un processus d'acceptation
de pour certains endroits de notre de
notre france / sur ces grandes éoliennes
sont peut-être pas aller au delà
pourquoi lancer un chantier colossal
comme celui ci en fin de quinquennat ça
aurait pu être une priorité ça aurait pu
être pensé avant
est ce que vous appelez un projet
colossal le projet france 2030
pour les laisser d'influx renouvelables
est ce qu'il n'aurait pas pu être lancée
et engagé au début du quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron plutôt qu'à quelques
mois de la présidentielle
d'abord un projet pour le lancer un tel
projet pour le lancer il faut avoir une
bonne réflexion à une solide ambition et
ça on peut pas on peut pas renier le
fait que l'audace est derrière tout ce
projet d'un 2030 c'est là aussi
très audacieux pouvoir imaginer ce
projet sur 2030 mais nul doute nous
allons y arriver puisque il ya déjà une
2019 je vous rappelle qu'on n'a pas
attendu longtemps il ya eu la loi la loi
énergie qui m'a cette loi d énergie qui
m'a dessiné déjà le profil de cet
aboutissement de 2030 alors cette loi
énergie climat elle est c'est une loi
qui allons la voir sur le terrain et
rendons nous chez les particuliers comme
dans les collectivités et voyons le
bénéfice qui a été fait par sept par
cette loi et vous verrez que chacun à
tirer vraiment que du que des meilleurs
que de l'application de cette loi donc
voilà une belle loi qui est non
seulement fait qu'ils aient fait bien
sûr à paris et qui est votée par
l'assemblée nationale mais qui a été
fait en concertation avec le terrain
donc on peut pas concertés pendant les
et et faire immédiatement donc une loi
cette loi 2010 un fait nager 2019 a été
une loi établie et donc il fallait pas
un livre appelé passer un petit peu de
temps en tout cas conséquences de la
crise on le sait on constate c les prix
de l'énergie qui augmente aujourd'hui
total qui a promis un chèque de 100
euros sur le gaz et 5 euros de remise
sur un plein en zone rurale un
commentaire sur sur cette démarche de
total
moi je trouve que c'est une démarche qui
qui est certainement en adéquation avec
eux avec ce que ce que total souhaite
faire de son image et qui répond à
un dé
à des français et qui font les
effectivement ils se sont aperçus que je
plains et on s'en aperçoit ni le plein
et terriblement augmenté je voudrais
vous dire que c'est pas rien 5 euros 5
euros parfois ces deux trois repas pour
certaines personnes donc il est
important que total puisse participer
à cette
à ce niveau social pour ils puissent
participer à l'économie et à la
diversification de cette économie en
retour de cette économie sur les plus
pauvres merci beaucoup pierre cabaret
d'avoir accepté notre invitation répondu
à nos questions ce matin sur rtl france
nous vous présentons nos excuses une
nouvelle fois pour l'absence de david
xavier weiss qui n'a pas pu nous
rejoindre ce matin effectivement c'était
un débat sur le nucléaire que l'on
aurait souhaité mais on vous remercie
infiniment aussi d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin pierre cabaret et
député la république en marge de haute
garonne